hello we're going to talk about your
thyroid and vitamin A most people
consider it vitamin A are merely to do
with your eyes and improving night
vision issues and the immune system but
it also has another function that's
related to your thyroid gland okay so
let's talk about that so there's two
forms of vitamin A you have the inactive
version okay that's like beta carotene
that's an all the vegetable family
carrots kale and spinach things like
that okay
inactive vitamin A is converted to the
active vitamin A that's called retinol
that's to know the animal products egg
yolks fish oils animal products grafted
dairy products butter things like that
with the help of the far right so we
have beta carotene that's converted to
retinol with the help of the forward so
you need a good healthy thyroid to make
this conversion and the other point I
want to mention is that most hypothyroid
cases are vitamin A deficient even if
they start consuming lots of
beta-carotene because they can't convert
it and on the flip side vitamin A is
needed to convert the inactive form of
thyroid t4 to the active form t3 so
vitamin A is very necessary in the
conversions of thyroid hormones and the
thyroid is necessary for the conversion
of beta-carotene into retinol so in
other words if you want to help your
thyroid you must start consuming more
vitamin A so you don't just want to get
beta-carotene from the vegetables you
also want to get the active form of
vitamin A if you have a thyroid problem
that's in the cod liver oil make sure
you get a high-quality one virgin cod
liver oil fish grass-fed dairy egg yolks
all are loaded with the active form of
vitamin A which is called retinol and
one last point if you have a hyper
thyroid it's just as important to
consume vitamin A these foods here for
that condition as it is for a hypo
thyroid condition thanks for watching hi
guys hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause
take the quiz now and we'll send you
report